こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん水32019年もあと1ヶ月とちょっとになりました
皆さん今年はどんな年だったでしょうかまぁ僕は
そんな炎上することもなく結構平和に遅れた1年だったなと思いますのでもないわけで
はなかったですけどそんな比較的平和な一年だったんですけども私1年間縛りプレイ
生活というものをちょっと前から始めておりまして
まずその歴史をとっていきましょう2016年に1年間おかしいを禁止しました
オレ流著者おかしいが好きすぎ
て太ってきたっていうのが原因で市で恫喝を禁止して new 清めようということで
2016にお菓子を禁止
2017年ラーメン禁止生活をしましたこれは試験し性格の反動で僕ラーメンしか食べ
ないようになっちゃって
なんで食いすぎた結果近郊診断で中性脂肪はヤバいことになってて健康を気遣ってして
いる17年は1年間ラーメンを建設しますか
して2018年て私をニックを検知しましたラーメンを禁じされたことはどうに逃げた
かというと
牛同10度に逃げてしまいました流動禁止っていうかよユーザーということでハードル
をちょっと上げさせていただき
トニックを1年間禁止それが2018年でした
そして今年2019年職募集バレーを終えた私は精神力を高めよう
ということで常に初診でラン張るということをもっと2世年間スーツ縛るということで
今年は1年間スーツで動画を撮らせていただいておりますそして期待2020年
[音楽]
なにしようかなーなにしようかなあの掃除機
それでもいい続きどれでもいいんですやりたくないよじゃないですめっちゃやりたいん
ですけども
何か簡単すぎてもやだしあの無理すぎる奴の自分苦しめることになるんでチョコ
いい塩梅の苦しさなぜ済み相棒家ガーデンがー
いや目くらいの鬼付近人がおかしい人結構良かったんですよどういう関係なんですね
あのちょうど僕にほどよいストレス負荷をかけるぐらいの1年菓子バリー
プレイの何かあればいいなと思いましてあの2020年はぜひ皆さんに考えて頂きたい
というわけである今日の動画では2020年の1年間縛りプレイの内容を皆さんに考え
て頂きたいと思っております入ったわけで全部コメント欄に書いてくださいあのまず
普通に全部見ますから落とし前にまくってちょっと来年なにしようか頑張って決めよう
と思いますってなんかねむずいんだよね
炭水化物禁止とかはマジで良い年ですしていますやもう難しいです僕が考えていたね1
出させていただくと1年間月はたちは毎日1回しなきゃいけない縛りプレイっていうの
があったんですけど
普通にしんどいなったは何柱か生活いく付かないなと思ってちょっとそれは
って感じですやることなかったでありますけどで何でもいいですも食でもいいし
禁止じゃなくてもいいですね1年間1日1回なんかやれところもいいしこれなら1年間
を通して僕がその1年間やり終えたときにすごいやりがいがあることができればいいな
と思っているので困ったときこそ
いつも動画を見てくださるみなさんが頼りだよ1年間の変化したり来年の1月1ずに
それがならすごかったらいいけど食べ物禁止目強かったんですよ
一年越しの焼肉とが1年後そのなんとかめっちゃ美味しかったからそんなに数ちょっと
ね二年後そのインパクトが無いなって感じだったんでそれじゃないんだ儲けが覚えてる
のはを行く剣士しまって行った時にはいろんな人に批判されて
エイリスが危ないよとか本当に心配と夜なんですけども
全然大丈夫だってくれたご心配ありがとうございました時本無茶なことはしないんで愛
という感じでございます何か自分で考えるのが一番いいし自分で考えると言われるかも
知れないですけどもなぜどれでもいいんですよ願いを求めて生きている人間なんで是非
何かおすすめの1年縛りがたら教えてください
個人的には8世帯でことだが特技を身につけるのところもいいですねもう禁止じゃなく
てそういうのとかでも全然いい
いいねぇぜひ何か良い案があったらコメント欄に書いてください特に期限はないですと
の来年までこのコメントがよく見てると思うんでいろんな1年間の絞りプレートかと
いってねちょっと曲バタバタするねあの東京に行ってきます
それかといって釣っ頑張るぞい
行かなきゃ街じゃないっ
me
あっはぁ